handy how'd it go it went okay
I have two cats and it's working but the
whole process was a little frustrating
frustrating in what way so um you know
kind of like this but I basically just
copied and pasted it on my code from
from you know the first cat made a
second cat had a cat one in a cat two at
count one and account two and all that
sort of thing it seems like a quick and
easy method right it was quick it wasn't
easy um what wait why why not so I
forgot to change one of the ones to a
two and so when I clicked on one of the
cats
it kept incrementing both of the cats
and that isn't the best the best way to
do things I see now um here's another
question if hypothetically I were to ask
you to scale this from two cats to say
five cats
what would you say like this isn't
scalable pardon me wants to say no I
don't want to do that but this method
probably wouldn't you know I mean
obviously this method would not be the
best way to do it I'm sure it could work
I would probably want to find a better
way to do it it's probably a wise
approach yeah
now if I were hypothetically to ask you
and Andy to do this and scale up to five
cats there is one thing that you
probably should be aware of and that has
to do with closures when you're adding
event listeners to elements several
elements in a closure inside of a loop
there's an easy trap you can fall into
now the next note is going to be a
reading note it's going to tell you
information about when you might fall
into that trap and how to get out of it